my guest this week is editor-in-chief of
daily wire calm editor-at-large of
Breitbart calm a syndicated columnist a
radio host and a New York Times
bestselling author you know me to throw
in anything else and then you got a
serious resume I mean I was doing some
research on you you pretty much do
everything that's all my time yeah you
keep this busy day yeah all right well
I'm very happy that you're here because
I have had all of Twitter basically
saying to me for about six months you've
got to talk to this guy this is the guy
who will either convert you to
conservatism or you guys are just gonna
hate each other I'll turn you into
flaming Bernie Sanders socialists yeah
that's that's pretty much pretty sure
that's not the director so it'll be a
conservative by the end of the
conversations all right well let's see
let's Allen territory yeah let's see
what happens but but a lot of people
also said that even even liberals that
that no abuse said I don't agree with
this valiant a lot sometimes I don't
even like him but there's there some
principle based around what he does
so that and that's pretty much it of
what I do here so that's why I wanted to
have you on well thanks for having me I
got a lot of requests to come on your
show so I'm glad you invited me yeah all
right so let's get to it so first off
you are actually born in LA and brought
up in LA I thought there were no
Conservatives in LA what the hell are
you doing here yes my parents were both
they voted for Carter in 76 and they
were Reagan Republicans and then because
we're Orthodox Jews religious Jews tend
to vote Republican and be culturally
conservative and so that's sort of the
milieu in which I grew up so yeah I
became conservative basically from from
birth I'm not I'm not a new convert
right so how is that growing up a
conservative as a kid because what's
that saying you know if you're not
liberal in your 20s you have no heart
and if you're not conservative in your
thirties you have no brain something
right yeah how was that as a kid yeah I
have no heart so it works out beautiful
yeah well howhow is that as a kid
growing up you're conservative as a kid
it doesn't it just doesn't sound it
doesn't sound right somehow
well again growing up in religious
communities a little bit different than
growing up in a non-religious community
religious communities tend to be more
conservative and in LA conservatism is
all about social issues right when it
comes to economics there's kind of the
the you'll see the people driving around
in the Mercedes Benz with the Bernie
Sanders sticker but everybody knows
they're full of it so there's a lot of
that in Beverly Hills right oh yeah oh
yeah and
okay you can just drive down to cars for
kids I need any day now just give it
away and enjoy yourself like I don't
understand why you need my money you
clearly have some of your own so anytime
but in LA it's all a cultural thing and
conservative versus versus leftist and I
like to distinguish leftist from
liberals so I don't think they're the
same thing
conservative versus leftist in LA is
very much about kind of a character
assumption if you're if you're a leftist
you're a good person if you're
conservative that means you're an
uptight John Lithgow type from Footloose
you know on anybody - that's what it
comes down to right so I definitely want
to dig into the difference between
liberals and leftists you because it's
something you focused on a lot from the
right and it's something that I focused
on a lot in the last year from the left
so we're gonna dive into that but let's
just do some election stuff sure first
let's get the easy stuff absolutely
stuff right yeah so this election seems
completely insane to me let's start with
Trump you're big on Trump I don't think
so
how you doing I think that I think
Trump's a loudmouth I think he's a
braggart I think that Trump is is bad
for American politics I think there's a
couple of things that I like about Trump
one is that he says things that are not
politically incorrect
the problem with Trump is that he fails
to distinguish politically correct from
just being a jackass
so there there is a difference I mean
there's a difference between being rude
and being politically incorrect right
right being rude is is telling megyn
kelly she's bleeding from her wherever
being politically incorrect is saying
that some immigrants across our southern
border are criminals that's politically
incorrect but it's not rude but saying
that megyn kelly is bleeding from her
wherever that's not politically
incorrect that's being a jerk so as part
of it that his people mistake the - so
because because the reign of political
correctness is so strong people have now
interpreted being politically incorrect
as just anything you say that pisses
someone off that means you're
politically incorrect and that's not
what political correctness is sure so
it's this conflation of just saying
anything and he's really good at that I
mean I've noticed the more I watch him
it really you can widdle him down to
some pretty basic stuff because he just
says a lot of circular logic stuff and
this person's great and that person is
great and they love me and they hate me
and that and he was actually never
really saying anything
well that is what sort of the genius
this is what I don't like about him and
it is the genius of him because we live
in a me culture and a me time and a me
media and so Trump is all about Trump I
mean that's that's really the only thing
that matters to him so if Vladimir Putin
insults him tomorrow that matters more
than a flattened reboot invade the
country right because all that matters
is Trump and so he speaks about himself
in the third person and everything that
he talks about is I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna build a wall I'm gonna fix I'm
gonna make a great deal I'm good for the
blacks I'm good for the Hispanics
no we're in there do I hear as a
conservative no we're in there do I hear
anything about what's the proper role of
government in my life which is the part
that I care about right the part I don't
care about Donald Trump right I don't
think he cares about me I don't think
that we should care about each other I
want him to leave me alone I want Barack
Obama alone so I can live that the
conservative principle there just yes
yes just just leave me alone like the
government was not meant to do this many
things
end of story I mean read the
Constitution is very explicit about the
things government is supposed to do and
pretty much nothing on Trump's list
except for maybe border security is
really something the government ought to
be doing and again what that comes down
to and this is the problem is I think
that what the danger of Trump is that
the left for a hundred years has fallen
in love with the idea of the strong men
I mean you go all the way back to
Woodrow Wilson and Woodrow Wilson is
writing about the president should be
the strongest man possible the only
limits on his power should be his vision
basically which you know could come
straight from Mussolini and Woodrow
Wilson was actually as close to a
dictator as America has ever had that's
carried through to FDR's credit to LBJ
to Obama on the right at least they made
overtures toward we're not going to have
the strongman who gets involved in your
life and fixes all your problems Trump
is the strongman and I think after after
so many years of a lot of Americans on
the right feeling emasculated by
President Obama telling them that their
racist sexist pig at homophobes and by
Hillary Clinton telling them that were
there to kind of testosterone e an
orientation toward the world basically I
wrote this yesterday I think that the
really response to Trump from the right
has basically been he's the biggest
swing and set of balls in the race and
because that's what he is I'm for him
and you hear that from Trump supporters
well he'll do something I maybe he will
maybe I don't know yeah it'll be good oh
that's all right so as a conservative
though so as a true assertive this must
make you feel crazy right I mean you
must be
enraged at your own party because it's
looking more and more everyday like he's
actually gonna win yeah I mean I don't
know who to be the most pest at honestly
and then you got you got the GOP
establishment which cannot get off the
Jeb Bush trend for the life of them and
just unify behind somebody like a Marco
Rubio and they hate Ted Cruz so much
they would side with Trump over Cruz
probably right so Cruz to them is too
far right right cruising and they think
he's unelectable and more than that Cruz
actually I think believes the things
they say they believe so he says I
believe in a small government I think
that we should cut the government I
think the government shouldn't be
important in people's lives and the RNC
which makes its money off government
being important to people's lives me how
much money would you give to a political
party if the government didn't matter in
your life right at the RNC would raise 0
dollars if no one cared what happened in
Washington DC and so Cruz scares them
from that angle I don't think Trump
scares them I think Trump Trump annoys
the establishment but he doesn't scare
the establishment so I'm annoyed at the
establishment I'm annoyed at you know
Cruz is a very good constitutional
conservative but he's just he's not a
great candidate by any stretch of the
imagination and then there are the Trump
people who are so populist and in love
with the the the feel of Trump that they
forget that they're that this guy could
actually be president like if he's
president what is that going to look
like so it's it's it's frustrating
definitely all the way across the board
and I think maybe the most frustrating
thing of all is that beating Trump is
actually not that hard Trump is a
schoolyard bully and and somebody needs
to just say to him in the last debate it
was so clear if you actually want to
stop Trump you can't do a Jeb did I mean
Jeb stood there and he said you know
Donald you know you're bit you're
bullying people and also stop being mean
to my mother
yeah really I mean all Trump is if my
thesis is correct that basically Trump
just represents the balls of American
politics and the only way to beat that
is to kick him in the balls right
figuratively speaking that's the only
way to do it and he can't really it
could work too it might work literally I
mean but the only way to really beat him
is for somebody on the stage to say to
him Donald you act like a big tough guy
you papa get 40 million dollars to play
with ya you've never had anyone say no
to you in your entire life you're a
pathetic weak specimen every time
somebody takes you off you turn as red
as the background on that stage the
other night I mean he actually faded
into the woodwork during that debate and
if anybody on the stage really needs to
shut the hell up and just
listen for a second it might be you
since you clearly know nothing about
anything so what does that tell you
about the rest of these guys that nobody
does it I get it it's not in Jeb's
character right it's just not there I'd
only it's in any other character yeah so
what does that say that about this this
group of people is I mean it is an
Obama's character Obama would do it yeah
and I think it's actually in Hillary's
character I think these I think that
folks on the Left understand that
presidential politics is a knife fight
and people on the right are constantly
engaged in this game where it's it's a
discussion over policy so Jeb Bush this
morning for example he's on he's talking
about Trump and he says something to the
effect of you know my goal as president
of the United States is to grow our GDP
from a 2% growth rate to a four percent
growth rate oh yeah that's gonna be
Trump yeah that's the solid argument
like they don't understand that most
politics comes it's unfortunate this is
the way it is most politics comes down
to character arguments once you get the
character arguments off the table then
you can have a good policy argument but
most people on the Left like to turn and
say to people on the right that you're
just bad people you're racist sexist
bigoted homophobe so we shouldn't listen
to you and and that's what Trump does so
well and so what you see on the right is
yeah but you're not a conservative
that's that's an argument about policy
it's not an argument about character
right so for a guy that obviously
doesn't like Bernie Sanders or Hillary
Clinton do you at least Envy the fact
that in their debates it seems to me
that it's much more substantive there's
at least you know they're really saying
I'm the progressive on the progressive
now you may hate all progressive ideas
but at least there's a you know you're
you you got the D plus from the NRA and
I got a C or whatever so it's a little
more of that so I think that they stay
away from the character attacks which I
which I appreciate that's that's good
yeah although I think that you know in
in Hillary's case some character attacks
would be necessary if Bernie actually
would like to win and not just run a
campaign at some point he's going to
have to say you're corrupt because
that's that sort of saying it though
right now and it's a little late right I
mean and she by the way she's vicious I
mean attacking him as a racist I'll say
a lot of bad things about Bernie Sanders
but calling Bernie Sanders is racist is
absurd and she's so set on I have to win
the ethnic minority vote that I'll send
out my surrogates like David Brock to
suggest he doesn't care about black
lives which is absurd you know I think
that I'd like to see a little more
character attacks on the on the left and
between them anyway right and and as far
as policy
I watched a couple of their debates I
have yet to see a significant area of
disagreement I think they're just coming
at it from we agree on everything it's
just a question of how we talk about it
Bernie says let's talk about it honestly
and Hillary says let's lie about it a
little bit to the people don't really
figure out what we're up to and then
we'll do it and it'll be too late right
so I sense at least with them there's a
there's a Hillary's trying to hit Bernie
on this that you're a big idea guy but
actually I can get some of this stuff
done now I don't know that the
Republicans would be any more inclined
when they say that birth order I mean
they say that but it's boring right
Christie was saying that in every debate
ready to have Rubio and Cruz go at each
other and then there's Chris Christie
doing the well I'm Josh Shooks I'm just
a governor I don't understand what
you're saying you know what are you
doing him southern yeah because because
it's stupid because it's a dumb thing to
do I mean he sounds like a he acts like
a hick when he does that Christie like
you're a governor of a major state
acting like you don't know how the
political game is played or like you
don't know what the Senate does I just
don't know what these people are arguing
about over here they're just in meetings
okay exactly Here I am you know I do
real things like hug the Obama is it
come on so is it all of politics
everybody's playing politics right now
at this level and nobody's playing
politics like where the real ideologies
are which is why I would like to see
what I would love to see I think it'd be
good for the country is the Sanders
versus Cruz raised right that would
actually be a fascinating race because
at that point may if Sanders can stay
away from the whole you're a racist
sexist bigoted homophobic we could
actually have a discussion about whether
socialism is a good idea or a bad idea
is income inequality something that we
ought to worry about or is it just
ramifications of a free-market system in
which people make voluntary transactions
happen it's that these would be
interesting conversations but we just
don't get to them right so with the real
battle of ideas though be if it was
Sanders and had Rand Paul not dropped it
there's a good cat that would have been
the yeah I mean you know my problem with
Rand Paul was always on foreign policy
I'm not an isolationist and so ran sort
of is but it's but yeah I mean that
that's it would be a battle of ideas
that would be worthwhile yeah so the
Republican Party in general and I hear
this a lot on the left you know that
it's this group of homophobes and races
and all this right and I've been
fighting against this I've been fighting
from the liberal side against yeah the
regressive left what I you know the
people that are on the far left to me
and I saw something interesting that you
retweeted and remind me who said this
but somebody made a point of saying that
this morning
Nikki hailey and an Indian news guy best
American Asian and Tim Scott an African
American have both endorsed Marco Rubio
who is Latin these are all the publicans
right so an Indian a black person and a
Latino and these are Republicans and Tim
Scott is a black Republican from the
south
somehow that messaging doesn't really
make it through does it well it doesn't
because they're not real black people or
real Latinos or real foreign or you know
of foreign extraction I mean nikki Haley
was born here but her parents are from
India that never met the point isn't at
the point of America that's what I would
think right now we've we've broken down
into the site entity politics that
really is quite sad and traps people in
a group identity rather than you're an
individual go out and make something of
yourself go out and do something and
this is a message that's not popular in
certain quarters when you say to people
look your life is in your own hands
there's a lot of responsibility that
comes with that which is you don't get
to blame society for your problems this
is why the I think the Bernie Sanders
argument the Hillary Clinton argument is
wrong you know Bernie Sanders he's ever
ever there tweet from Bernie Sanders is
something like we live in a world where
those weathers massive income inequality
and we need to do something about that
and I think to myself well that's called
a world of reality I mean every society
in history has had income inequality
including communist ones and you're not
showing me a villain right you're saying
reality is bad blame society for all the
problems show me an actual villain and
I'm happy to fight them show me some
some ghost villain and I can't fight
ghosts I just can't right so when you
hear that stuff though do you
acknowledge at some level that there's
some level of crony capitalism that
keeps making the big companies bigger
and crushing all of the small companies
and so I think he's striking to that
point but I guess he's not doing it in
like a really direct well right if you
were attacking crony capitalism he in
the Tea Party are on the same page I
mean the problem with with the Occupy
Wall Street movement which was
supposedly ripping crony capitalism as
they were saying crony capitalism is bad
therefore the government should pick
more companies to help or should
nationalize companies outright which is
not the solution right if you say crony
capitalism capitalism is bad first of
all I don't like the term crony
capitalism because it's not capitalism
it's corporatism right capitalism is not
being being a person who operates in
business
not make you a capitalist business
people take loans and subsidies from the
government all the time that's not a
capitalist thing to do it's it's it's a
it's a self-interested thing to do but
self-interest in capitalism are not
identical if you wanted to actually
fight crony capitalism then cut off the
tie between government and the private
sector completely which I would
certainly prefer right and this is part
of the Republican Party that I dislike I
think there's a certainly corporatist
side of the establishment republican
party that is very much in favor of
government involvement the economy and I
don't like that in the slightest but
that's not Bernie's real critique if
could because if if it were a full
free-market system if the government
weren't reaching out to people and by
the way the government said if you're
going to argue against crony capitalism
you also have to argue against
government subsidized loans for people
who can't afford them for houses right
which causes massive economic crashes
which burn apparently doesn't oppose
right I mean he would like more of those
things right would like all of us to
subsidize bad you know but folks bad
credit taking out loans if you actually
if you got rid of all those things if
you got rid of government involvement
Bernie Sanders would still think that
something was wrong if Bill Gates is
earning a lot of money and somebody at
the bottom is earning none yeah you see
somebody in a room with $5 in somebody
with one and he immediately says the guy
with $5 must have stolen something from
the guy with $1
whereas I say I have no evidence of that
until you show me that evidence may be
the guy with $5 produced more than the
guy with $1 right so I'll follow that
line of thinking so then where where do
we get to a point where it's like to me
at some level there should be some sort
of progressive tax it shouldn't be
necessary you know when they talk about
the 1% who the studies are sort of all
over the lace but it sounds like if you
earn about 400 grand a year you're in
you're in the 1% I'm not in the 1% I am
you're in the 1% all right well good
event took me a long time to gather know
some money no that's why I'm in the 1%
oh there's people who ever said that how
to take care of their money but ok so
I'm mentally I'm proud of that fact I'm
gonna I'm not gonna act like everybody
acts ashamed about how much money they
earn in this country I think there's the
only thing that's charming about Donald
Trump is that I think that you should be
proud of how much money you earned in
this country because if you worked to
get there I mean I've spent a lot of
money to go to law school and then I
spent a lot of time slogging in the
trenches and now I make a really good
living and I work a lot of hours to make
that really good living and my wife you
know we had to pay her entire medical
education out of pocket and she's gonna
be a doctor and she's gonna make a real
good living good for her good for me
good for good for anybody who earns a
living in this country that's it that's
it that's a good thing right as far as
the progressive tax no I think
progressive tax a bunch of crap I think
they do well what about at some point so
you get to ten million dollars a year
that it could be progressively you know
up a little now you just don't believe
in that no because I don't see why you
deserve a bigger percentage of my money
because I make more money right you you
all taxes are is a is a gangster
shakedown and so when when and that's
all they are and so we can all agree
that some gangster shakedowns are
worthwhile because we have to pay for
police but the idea that it here's the
problem with any sort of regressive tax
there are three in this is just the
general problem with progressive
taxation you have three people in a room
two of them are not Bill Gates and one
of them is they vote two-to-one that
they should take half of Bill Gates as
well okay this is a simplified version
of American politics yeah the question
here is my basic rule for all
legislation and all taxation if you pass
this law are you willing to shoot the
person who disobeys because that's what
the government is the government is just
a big shooting people machine right
that's what the government does that the
insult in whether talking national
defense or the police there are certain
laws where you pass them and you say if
you disobey this law and if you resist
me with a gun I'm willing to shoot you
so what laws are you willing to shoot
somebody over this seems to me a pretty
good measure of MI well so for example
for taxation yes so the question is are
you willing to shoot people who don't
pay taxes if those taxes go for the
National Defense the Ted that protects
us all the answer is yes because if
nobody pays that tax then presumably
everybody dies in some sort of terrorist
attack but if you're gonna ask me you
know are you willing to pay a
progressive tax for whatever stupid
government bull they're pushing today
and am I willing to shoot somebody over
that no I think the purpose of the tax
is just as important as the percentage
of it so is that really the problem that
we have no idea at this point where our
money goes absolutely we just don't even
now I'm here you know Bernie will say
I'm rate you know he talked to that guy
at the Town Hall yeah and the guy said I
earned forty one thousand dollars a year
and Bernie admitted your taxes will go
up and then he explains well the health
costs are gonna go down or whatever
which may or may not make no sense he
says I'm going to tax you five thousand
dollars and you can get ten thousand
dollars back in medical service what
magic what magical box did you make that
happen and is there are there doctors
and the
that's when he said that everything well
if you're healthy if the government's
that cut it they wanna say I wish left
his solutions works is that are the
easiest solutions in the world right
it's a recession tax everybody at a
hundred percent redistribute the wealth
and tunde's the recession is over
yeah they don't work there they're crap
by the way they're also immoral you know
then the left the left talks about these
things as though it's moral it's not
moral to steal other people's wealth
just because you're poorer than they are
you